there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock all right it's Tuesday once
again and that means it's time for our
regular episode it's a 13 o'clock
podcast this is episode 122 damn the one
before the Christmas special yeah
usually but this one this topic I even
want to do this for like a year because
I only just found out about this like
not very long ago when I was doing
research for my book that faces Vil in
the second one and it's also been
requested a couple times to you by some
of our canadian listeners so i'm excited
that we're finally getting a chance to
do it and i've done actually a lot of
it's a very broad topic and i've done
like a lot of reading about it and a lot
of research about it so i can't cover
everything that happened over the time
but you know all kind of give sort of an
overview and hopefully you guys will be
interested enough to kind of look more
into it because there's a lot of
information about it out there so we'll
get into that a little bit later on now
let's see what do we got for shoutouts
today I don't remember if I mentioned
this before but I have uploaded the
audiobook files for the faceless villain
volume 2 yeah just wait it was a process
huh yeah they and actually last time I
checked a CX which was earlier today it
actually said the status of it was
headed to retail so I'm guessing that it
passed all their little stringent yeah
and so now it's getting to the point
where eventually it'll go for sale so it
shouldn't be all that much longer
because I know a couple of you have
asked about it so it'll only be a few
more days I promise and then it will be
available for sale also let's see what
else
our latest movie review was The Wicker
Man from 1973 not the remake with the
classic one so go check that out if you
haven't already also check out our
Zazzle store cuz I added some new
products like I put our logo on some
various different products so you can
check those out I'm also still working
on some new t-shirt designs I'm doing a
Kukulcan one then I'm going to put on a
shirt and I'm probably also going to put
on a mason jar cuz we have two that's
gonna go and you know I'm also work I'm
gonna do a wandering whim one and some
other ones so that should be up sometime
in the new year he's jumping into a box
yeah so like if you hear like she's
turning a paper right now yeah that's
her box that her Christmas presents came
in and I left it in here for her to play
in she likes the Box more than presents
well she's got friends yeah she hasn't
got the price she has been trying to
like open him she was trying to get in
and when I was wrapping up and I'm like
no one I saw Christmas even though she
doesn't care she she's making a nest in
there she is yeah yeah look at her she
loves paper she loves to eat paper she
was a tear up a perhaps she comes in she
comes in mommy's office like in the
morning
and she goes underneath my little thing
I have a little cubby with a little
thing with a bunch of papers in it and
she comes in she jumps in the cubby
pulls everything out and then chews it
up and it's like alright I'm done then
she leaves it's just this big pile of
paper floor that I need to clean up
that's all right though she's having a
good time so other than that I think
that's probably pretty much oh and I
have we have two new patrons that I have
to say hello to that's right first of
those is Olly
hello they're very very appreciative of
all you guys out there and the second
ones name isn't Mike so hi you guys and
thank you very much also like to thank
our fan Eric for another generous PayPal
donation he sends us one every now and
again it's really awesome and much
appreciated yeah well it's funny we
never really can't break the 500 barrier
it'll almost get the 500 we'll lose
somebody you know they got bills to pay
it goes back down and get some new ones
just bounce us around right there around
500 getting there slow it's like good I
think for as much and like I said we
don't have any subscribers yeah true
5000 I don't think what we're almost Oh
Robles 5000 aren't we yeah we made good
patreon money for the amount of
subscribers that we have yeah just not
very many well yeah some people like why
why do you guys why don't you guys have
more subscribers and I'm going to tell
you because we don't buy them a lot of
those a lot of these shows actually buy
subscribers and views well yeah and that
moves them up in the in the algorithms
you know so we don't do that
I just wanna like the show yeah that's
just regular natural ones you don't like
me for me is what I'm saying it's like
we've never well I not like I could
afford to pay for viewers or anything
anyway but I don't I wouldn't do that
just because I don't know it just don't
think it's that much I think it probably
wouldn't cost him out or no 50 bucks for
a thousand viewers maybe I just feel
like it's pointless because if there
comes a point when a whole bunch of
people are doing it then you doing it
isn't gonna help you any you know well I
got a friend it does you know little
Matt yeah he says somehow he knows
ladies people in Southeast Asia I mean
he's like a promoter yeah and and all
they do is follow subscribe and watch
other people and they have programs to
help them do it yeah it moves you up in
the algorithms then you start generating
more natural natural words on top of
that so it's kind of like advertising
booths yeah I considered it but I don't
know like I said I feel like it's just
kind of a thing we're at and this is why
I don't usually pay for advertising
because I feel like if you can only pay
like you know use a little Facebook ads
and it's like 5 bucks 10 bucks 30 bucks
whatever and it's like I feel like you
don't get enough back from that to
justify it's like if you if you can
afford to pay a shit-ton then yeah
you're gonna like reap a huge dividend
from that but if you can only afford to
like pay like $100 a month and I don't
think it's like worth you see these
people with millions of subscribers
that's not natural yeah or didn't start
off natural you know they got boosts
yeah it's like those bodybuilders you
think
naturally you're [ __ ] crazy I know
those dudes are taking it you know some
of it you know their person can't look
like that without not naturally drug in
him well especially these new these new
body builders and they look at Arnold
Schwarzenegger go yeah that that'd be
okay for like back then yeah yeah
classic physique you know Arnold was
roided-out - you know these guys look
now it's just I would never do that well
it's not it gets to a point where it
just doesn't look anymore around my
waist you know it just starts to look
strange and it's like not attractive
there's a point there's a point of
diminishing returns with everything you
only get so big then it's just kind of
like getting plastic surgery like a
little bit you looks okay but once you
get to you then you start looking like
somebody peeled your head back and they
pulled it on the back of your neck you
know what I mean that's it and you can't
move the muscles in your face so I think
that's pretty Oh what's his name
Gavin cannonball Rosa named brenell Burt
Reynolds if Burt Reynolds facelift
there's something else at every turn
Rousey expected if you have not on a bet
gonna look like I just imagine like the
plastic surgeon like putting his foot on
the back of his neck I know that's not
that's just yeah okay so we thank the
patron - patron donors and the paypal
dinners and everything like that and
again I'll say it and if you want to
financially support the show blah blah
I'll do that at the end now like I said
this is a topic I've been wanting to do
a really long time but I've had at least
at least three requests for this also
now this is how this came about when I
was researching faceless villain 2 which
covers you know 1960 1979 I started
coming across all these unsolved murders
that took place in London Ontario Canada
and I noticed that so many of the cases
were written up in this book called
murder City by Michael Arndt field who
was a former London Ontario cop and is
later became a criminologist and now he
has a show called to catch a killer that
he's on and stuff like that so and he
also runs like a cold case
where he has like people working on cold
cases so I bought the book for research
purposes and started reading it and it
turned out and here's something that I
didn't know and I'm imagining a lot of
people probably didn't know this either
is that between the years of 1959 and
1984 London Ontario Canada was home to
the largest known concentration of
serial killers in one small area here's
the thing this blows my mind at the time
in question London Ontario was less than
200,000 people population wise it's
about a hundred and forty thousand
hundred fifty thousand people somewhere
in the neighborhood of six to nine
serial killers were operating in that
area during this time period now in his
book he says now if you extrapolate to
like a big mega city like New York City
or Los Angeles he's like taking you to
account there population density in the
same time period that would be the
equivalent of 90 serial killers walking
around in New York or LA at the same
time like during the same time period 90
yes not not he said between 80 90 yes
like ten times as many so this is some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and they're still I mean
he has some theories about why it might
be like why this particular thing
happened in this particular place but
nobody knows for sure its prime sure
it's like kind of a conflation of tons
and tons of different factors which also
saw a spike in crime in other cities as
well but you know why this particular
city like seemingly had the highest
concentration of serial killers in the
world at the time as far as it is known
it's just I mean it's a crazy crazy
thing so there were between in this time
period there were 29 of these murders 13
of them I believe were solved were and
were attributed to three separate serial
killers other ones unsolved set and but
some of the other ones were a
to work they know they were connected
they just never caught the person that
did them you know what I mean
three of the serial killers were caught
but there were other ones that were not
caught but there are still you know kind
of you know like it they knew they were
connected because of the similar modus
operandi and all of that sanitized stuff
now what ended up happening with the
backstory of Mike alarm fields book
murder City which is like there it's
very good I like I recommend it I've
read the whole thing through then I've
skimmed through it like two or three
more times what ended up happening was
that there was a cop a detective
sergeant in London Ontario he started
working there in the 50s and he worked
there until 1979 and since you know
London Ontario was not a huge you know
metropolis or anything like that so when
all of these crimes started happening
they were kind of understaffed so this
poor dude got stuck with a whole bunch
of these cases now one thing that he did
and this was you have to think that this
was an era before the term serial killer
was he had even really been coined or
was even in common use this was before
the age of profiling on a large scale
they didn't really know anything about
you know sexual psychopathy or any kind
of paraphilias or anything like that or
you know things that would lead you to
say oh this guy's gonna be a serial
killer later on you know I mean like
early warning signs and stuff all of
that was either not really in the common
vernacular it wasn't really all that
well-known but this guy Dennis Alsop
seems to have had like an almost it was
just this kind of like weird sense of
this type of thing like even though he
didn't have a way to explain it because
they didn't have the vocabulary back
then but he really had an intuition for
which crimes were related and stuff like
that another thing was he was super
super dedicated all of these crimes that
happen in London Ontario and some that
happened in other places that were not
his jurisdiction and after he moved and
retired and stuff like that he kept
everything he can
all the copies of all the Case Files
copies of all the crime-scene
photographs copies of everything put it
all in boxes and kept it in his basement
so this guy was kind of like a
natural-born prototype profiler yeah
before there was even a word for them
what was his name again Dennis also okay
now when he passed away in 2011 he knew
that his son would be the one going
through all his stuff so his son found
this big-ass you know treasure trove of
all this stuff from all the crime scenes
that if it had been left with the police
department it probably wouldn't been
kept because they throw things out after
a while you know to make room for any
stuff um you know and things get missed
by all that stuff right so he had kept
all this stuff so his son found it
Dennis Allsop jr. and since he knew
Michael Armfield and Michael Armfield
had been a cop in London Ontario he gave
it to him so the book murder City is
basically I feel like if it wasn't for
Dennis I'll stop keeping all of this
stuff then maybe no one would have even
known about all this stuff going on like
all these interconnected murders because
like I said and it just happened in the
United States too
in the 50s and 60s there were
jurisdictional problems it's not like
now where you can like upload somebody's
DNA to a national database and in two
seconds they're like Oh Nick it's this
guy you know I mean they didn't do that
back then it's like they didn't even
like [ __ ] towns do you talk to each
other it's like somebody could serial
killer or somebody over here and then
they go to like a town our province over
and do the same [ __ ] over there and no
one would connect them really unless
they you know happened to go over there
and it's like it never happened right
you know what I mean same thing happened
here same thing happen in Canada so I'm
gonna I can't cover like all the crimes
that happen during this comes to there's
just so many the vast majority of them
were sexual crimes against women and
children both boys and girls mostly
girls uh three of them were little boys
but and like I said there there were so
many killers and so many of them are
interconnected and they're not sure
which ones are connected and which ones
are aren't but we'll kind of go into
that a little bit too but this just it
it's just such an interesting thing to
me and it's like I want to I kinda want
to go into at the end I was gonna talk
about it now but maybe I'll talk about
at the end about why this particular
City you know ended up being this way
like I said now the book that you got
this from was a book that you were
research and out of to help you write
faceless villainous has done one or two
to two yeah so a lot of what was the
name of this book we should probably
plug it murder City murder city oh yeah
he's written another one he wrote one
called mad city about about Wisconsin -
the capital city killings and all that
kind of sounds like a good book but it's
it's actually fascinating like I said he
not only goes into all the murders that
happened and which ones were probably
interconnected and stuff but he also has
a really good breakdown of different
types of serial killers different types
of sexual killers different type of
rapist topologies so it's just like kind
of all the most recent research into
types of serial killers and why they
offend and all the different kinds of
paraphilias that they have and you know
which ones are predictors of other
things and it's it's like a it's like a
fetish sort of but it's kind of like
it's it's generally something that's
connected with a turn-on yeah but it's
something that's weird it's it's a
particular type of fetish that if you
have it it's usually would lead you to
commit a crime you know what I mean got
like that Russian guy like necrophilia
yeah like that Russian guy I think was
back in the 70s in the Soviet Union he
was into those school boys need saw
through their feet
yes shoes and everything that was his
perfume it's that type of thing it's
it's any kind of time in a film of it
you can watch it this [ __ ] bizarre
you see yeah big kid was dead but he was
did you see that son I actually saw it I
saw on YouTube yeah yeah yeah he works
he was kind of like there is a
schoolteacher I think yeah something
kind of like their version of the Boy
Scouts yeah he was telling he's making
him taller by hanging him yeah he'd
resuscitate him to the sometimes he'd
let him die up there
yeah and cut do their feet with the
shoes on it that was his big thing with
the hat yeah that's exactly what a
paraphilia would be it would be some
kind of weird specific fetish Asteria
the objective you get it yeah that you
or that you would have to commit a crime
to get it
yeah because pedophilia you know you
don't necessarily have to kill the
person yeah but you know what I mean
it's so it would result in an illegal
active yeah this guy here he was into
those schoolboy shoes
wanted to cut him with her them saw with
the feet with the feet in it yeah weird
yeah that's what I mean it really seems
like a very specific yeah and he
actually in murder City he actually
talks about the psychologist John money
who he's kind of controversial in other
ways but he actually did come up with a
fairly reasonable sounding thing about
why why people why people develop these
types of paraphilias it's almost always
men not usually women they thinks that
maybe it's because because usually a
paraphilia develops in childhood it
develops around a particular person or a
particular type of person or a
particular object or a particular body
part or something like that and it
usually comes about if the kid is
punished or shamed for sexual behavior
that's usually something that happens
and he thinks that usually it's men
because men are generally more visually
oriented and so something bad is
happening to them like some traumatic
thing like for instance they get
sexually you know abused when they're
younger and they fixate visually on a
particular object or a particular type
of person like a photograph or something
like that then that will kind of become
imprinted it will become imprinted
during their childhood weird so yeah
that's that's the theory anyway so that
was something that he talked about in
there but like I said this is a really
good book just not just you know for
this particular time period this
particular city but also just kind of a
general serial killer party must be kind
of rare because you know I don't ever
remember fixating or B imprinting on any
one thing more than anything else well I
met girls I liked women when I was a
little
yeah well it's not like things had to be
a certain way
well yeah but see that's that's because
you had because you were a normal person
and had a generally pretty normal
upbringing up right
they said usually it has to do with
someone who's like either you know their
brain is messed up or their upbringing
is messed up or both right you know what
I mean that's it it doesn't happen in
healthy children I remember being like
by the time I was like six or seven you
know man I like those high stockings all
women yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah we'd come across you know Playboy
magazines and [ __ ] you're not I mean
didn't get paid with them girls dressed
in a man well you wait when you're a kid
yeah and that's a thing and interesting
too I think that sexuality develops at a
pretty young age because I remember
being pretty little yeah being
interested yeah being an interested in
sexual imagery and stuff even when I was
like four or five years yeah
of course I was you know but I was never
like my family didn't like [ __ ] on me
for it cuz no 70s they didn't people
didn't hang out didn't have hang-ups
including some of these [ __ ] people
yeah but yeah so what I'm gonna do is
like I said at the end I might talk a
little bit about you know why he thinks
this particular city or so you know some
of the reasons behind why this
particular city might have turned out
the way it did but I also kind of want
to go into some of the little specific
crimes that happened during the same
period whether some of them were kind of
related like I said I can't go to all of
them because there were a [ __ ] ton so
I'm just kind of gonna summarize a few
of them now this one was actually this
was a little bit before the prescribed
period of the book but he mentions it in
in there just as kind of like a not I
didn't want to say like a teaser but
it's like something that was kind of a
bellwether of what was gonna happen
later on and this would this actually
happen in January of 1956 and it was a
little girl and her name was Susan catio
and she was 6 years old now her and a
bunch of her siblings and little friends
they were playing like by a church like
in a little churchyard and they were
messing around outside in the yard or
whatever now evidently this guy walks up
to them he was described as a tall thin
unshaven man between 35 and 40 years old
wearing a Russian style fur or wool hat
a light tan or brown overcoat and
galoshes with heavy buckles now he said
that he's like oh I have an appointment
to meet with father O'Rourke who was you
know the priest that was at that
particular church so he didn't know what
that priest name was he said yeah I have
an appointment for him so I'm just
waiting around for him and then he says
to Susan she's like oh you you have to
come with me he's gonna I'm gonna give
you something and so then like the other
kids said that this man that Susan
turned toward them like she took him by
the hand was like oh okay and then she'd
she was six yeah and then she turns
around she says this man's gonna give me
something and then they took off
now her brothers and friend like the
friend who was a girl like kind of ran
after it was like wait a minute I don't
think that's right and then she slipped
and fell on the ice and like busted up
her face so then the brothers were like
oh it's fine so then they just went home
and then suit so of course Susan never
came back right and then it's just weird
how like naive I guess people were but
like me there's around a church and he
knew who this and he knew the priest was
part of the church community you know
yeah so that's probably what they
thought so they've you know obviously
she gets reported missing much later
that night after she never came home so
but they didn't find her until the next
morning they found her about two blocks
away she had been raped and she was
actually she died of exposure actually
so I guess she was just raped and left
there perhaps unconscious so that's like
I said that was kind of one of the first
well why is he dying exposure though
there had been more damage that's what I
mean she was knocked unconscious and she
was just left out there huh and her
clothes were regained consciousness
right yeah but we don't know how bad the
damage was like maybe she'd been beaten
on the head several times something's
missing in that story well
well I'm just giving you this quick
summary yeah but they're not they're not
giving us the coroner's report yeah well
it might be in the book but I don't
remember what I said I just that's what
I'm saying so don't always just go by
what I'm saying because sometimes
there's more information out there that
I just write here you know that I didn't
put in my notes because I was just you
know summarizing stuff good because you
know you can't just knock somebody out
and then walk off and them died of
exposure they come to so it has a head
oven massive head trauma that's it oh
well I'm sure it probably was and like I
said she was only six years old right so
like I said that was kind of the first
inkling of [ __ ] that was gonna go down
and this actually wasn't in London
Ontario proper and it was a little bit
outside of it so then there was another
one and this was actually kind of this
is a very very famous case still this
happened in 1959 and this was the murder
of 12 year old Cheryl Lynn Harper
usually just called Lynn Harper now she
her parents like were on her dad was
actually in the Royal Canadian Air Force
so she lived on the base with her
parents like in the married officers you
know barracks or whatever now so she's
12 years old it's June 1959 she's
hanging out with her friend who's 14 and
his name is Steven Truscott and his
parents also lived around there and so
they knew each other
so he's riding her he's riding his bike
and she's on the handlebars now
according to him he dropped her off at
this intersection and then he was riding
off on his bike and he turned around and
he saw her getting into a car and then
she was not seen alive after that they
reported her missing and all this other
kind of stuff two days later
June 11th they found her body in a farm
woodlot she had been raped and strangled
with her own blouse
now the horrible thing about this was
that Steven Truscott 14 years old was
pretty much immediately arrested for her
murder
the
as they said well she was he was the
last one to see her alive he was known
to hang out like around the woodlot
where the body was found even though all
the kids hung out there because they
knew the farmer the farmer was kind of a
younger guy and like a lot of kids hung
out there and worked there in the summer
and stuff like that and I think a lot of
the [ __ ] that happened to was because
the the coroner the guy who did the
autopsy he kind of said he's like oh
well she um she died around the time
that Stephen Truscott said that he last
saw her so the kid like I said he's 14
they put him on trial like three months
later they try him as an adult and they
sentenced him to hang damn right and
it's like and he's in jail for like a
long time right now eventually you know
cooler heads prevailed and they were
like he's 14 he's like we can't hang a
fourteen-year-old red and really like I
said the only evidence they had was that
one he was the Latin he admitted that he
had been with her that day and you know
so that was all they had and it seemed
like they were kind of trying to
railroad him a little bit because this
was kind of a crime that doesn't usually
happen and they're just like okay well
we just want to like use the book on it
and [ __ ] like that
so he's in prison for a long time even
though he's maintaining his innocence
now later on he was eventually paroled
he changed his name he married he had
children had lived a normal life but in
the interim this investigative
journalist wrote a book about it where
she pretty much said look he was
railroaded he didn't do it and it caused
this big stir like even the judge that
had originally sentenced him to hang was
like oh well that journalist should be
put in prison for like public mischief
and all this other Christian right yeah
yeah
and stuff like that so but the more like
people started talking about the book
they're more like yeah maybe that maybe
he was kind of railroaded because it
seemed like they sort of you know didn't
love ahead to a Justin Lincoln right
so it's just like well he was there so
he's the fall guy yeah that would never
fly and never fly in any court in the
United States and said maybe like
Louisiana Texas maybe back in the day
yeah they have to have some kind of
physical evidence to link it yeah I mean
like I said this seemed like a it was a
rare type of crime they just wanted to
get it out of their face and you know so
they were just like oh well you're it
pretty much so honestly like I said even
though he was paroled a few years later
he didn't actually get a formal
acquittal until 2007 um they did give
him a large financial payout he had been
out of prison for quite a while at that
time but even though um you know they
apologized and all this other kind of
stuff but his name kind of is linked
with this murder
even though probably he didn't do it
although it should be said that hit that
Lynn Harper's family were really mad
that when he got acquitted
later because they thought that he did
it but the thing is there are a whole
bunch of other suspects that they didn't
really look into very much at the time
and honestly um I think one of the most
one of the most what's the word I'm
looking for probably one of one of the
ones that's most likely I think missing
them yeah that was the word I was
looking for was this guy named Alexander
Khaled Chuck now he was also a suspect
in Susan Caddy's murder which had
happened three years before now he was
also on this airbase he was like on Air
Force Base in the area he was known as
the base drunk he also had previous
convictions for exhibitionism like
exposing himself at one point he lured a
ten-year-old girl into his car and
showed her a bag full of women's
underwear so that type of stuff and
usually dudes and he kind of goes into
this in the book usually dudes that
start out as exhibitionist or peeping
toms or something like that
later develop these sort of attack
Philly's become rapists and serial
murderers and things like that
not all of them obviously but it is an
early indicator so he had a lot of that
kind of [ __ ] going on he was in the area
and there were also some other he had
some other like sort of minor
convictions for that type of thing later
on like when he moved around now he
ended up they never actually got him
brown on any of the murders or anything
like that he actually ended up in a
mental hospital later on and ended up
drinking himself to death in about 1975
I think it was but he seemed a pretty
likely suspect there was this other guy
they've never given his actual name
because I guess they don't have enough
you know they don't have enough evidence
to kind of and they don't want to like
get in legal trouble I guess but he's
usually referred to as Larry Talbot
which I'm like oh like from the werewolf
movie that's pretty funny but yeah so
this was another guy and there was
another investigator that thinks that
this Larry Talbot person might have been
the guy that the guy that killed her but
the weird thing was the investigator who
first put this guy's name forward he's
like I first thought of him when this
guy broke into my house and sexually
assaulted my girlfriend and then shot me
with a pellet gun yeah so he started
investigating this guy and that's when
he started thinking that maybe he was
responsible for not only like Lynn
Harper's murder but maybe a couple other
ones as well so he supposedly had like a
shoe print that matched one that was
found at the scene and he had the same
type of blood which was type-a blood
that was found at the scene also he
supposedly allegedly had something
called a rape kit in his trunk of his
car that he carried around just in case
he ever came across anybody so that was
like another one but the sad thing this
is kind of he goes into this as a long
chapter about the Lynn Harper murder
just because of the kind of miscarriage
of justice with his poor 14 year old kid
that was just riding along with his
little friend on the bike and suddenly
he's in prison for murder
so you know so there's that whole thing
going on and then let's see there was
now this one this happened actually in
1963 this one to me
sounds like probably the husband but
there was another similar one later on
that might have been but they actually
usually include this one now this is the
murder of Margaret Schuyler she had a
husband named Phillips they lived in
this house now she was pregnant at the
time I don't think they'd been married
very long I think it was a shotgun
wedding type of situation
Philip was kind of a drunk kind of had
rage issues not super happy about having
to marry this pregnant with this woman
that he'd knocked up or whatever
allegedly so it's a few days before it's
a few days after Christmas now
apparently the sealers are supposed to
be having a party so like all the all
these guests are supposed to be coming
over at 8 o'clock so all the guests
start getting there and Margaret is not
there and Philip is already half south
and he says oh we got in a fight she got
mad and then she stormed off to go to
her parents house right only problem was
the car was still in the garage it was
freezing cold outside she was pregnant
like I said and her parents lived over
an hour away by car yeah so is she gonna
walk yeah so she's gonna walk yeah so
they didn't actually find her for a
month a month later they found her
frozen body not really that far from her
house now her clothes had all been taken
off they were all scattered around she
didn't appear to have been sexually
assaulted they determined that she had
not been killed at that spot but had
been killed somewhere else and then
transported and dumped one of the
weirdest things they thought was that
they didn't find a coat so they said
either the killer took it or she went
out into the into the snow without a
coat or just killed him
Philip probably killed her in the house
and then took her out in the car maybe
and dumped her or something like that
which is what I'm thinking now they also
she also had an ex-boyfriend that had
followed her when she moved when she
married and moved to this from new city
so they thought it's possible that the
ex-boyfriend could have been stalking
her and maybe saw her come out and
you know and then grabbed her and did
whatever so fill up or the ex-boyfriend
were never you know there was never
enough evidence even though to me like I
said it sounds like the husband because
they said in the house like I said all
the party guests got there and said that
Philip was acting really weird and
really nervous and said yeah she just
took off and then there was like a roast
in the oven still and like half prepared
food like on the counter and stuff so it
looked like there just been a fight and
then some bad [ __ ] had happened so there
was actually another one that happened
like that much later in 1978 and that
was the murder of Irene McDonald who was
31 and her husband actually was later
convicted it was almost the exact same
situation where he was like yeah we had
a big fight and she stormed off and I
don't know where she went and then later
on he got convicted for killing her um
and but although they never found
Irene McDonald's body but according to
friends and acquaintances of Donald
Spindler who was the husband he had
bragged that he had killed her and then
soaked her body in lye or acid and then
dumped what was left into Lake Huron
which is why they never found it so they
never found the body but he was
convicted anyway even though they never
found it so let's see where we're at
we're probably at we're at 36 minutes so
I think I'm going to take a break and
then when we come back we'll talk about
some more murder cases that happened in
London Ontario during this time period
when it was the serial killer capital of
the world and then we might talk about a
couple of the reasons why this
particular City this particular time why
it happened in this particular way
because it was Canada I guess so we're
gonna take a break and we'll be back in
just a minute
okay everybody Jenny's got some new
shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job autumn where they
found making Jenny they were very fun
and thank you very much I think they
came out right yeah good they're very
high-quality shirts Jenny and I we're
sure our own shirts at certain times
when we're trying to put spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
you
selves if you go ahead and pick up on
these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them
links in the description WWL calm at 13
o'clock yeah so go check out our store
at wwl calm / 13 o'clock we got these
four cool new t-shirt designs plus all
our old ones if you'd rather get one of
the old ones but these ones are awesome
and you should check them out they're
also available in women's cut and they
look really cute JD's got some so thank
you go check about
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century vol 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format before when it was
ostensibly
the serial killer capital of the world
yeah I know it's really weird I mean
like you know New York and LA have had
four or five serial killers running
around at once which is bad enough but
to have like nine yeah in a city this
small well there's kind of yeah well
we'll get into them and like I said I
wanted to go over a few more like some
more of these cases that happen now
let's talk about the case of Georgia
Jackson this happened in February 1966
now she was in with the Jehovah's
Witnesses she was 20 years old she
worked in a like a suburb called Alamo I
guess is how you pronounce it I'm not
sure if any Canadians will correct me
she worked in like a you know what they
would call I guess a soda fountain type
of thing but you know made milkshakes
and [ __ ] like that
she usually closed it up at 6 o'clock
now this early yeah well it was you know
wintertime and milkshake but yeah so she
worked in there now she was last seen
she got off of work and then somebody
apparently who had been stalking her
you know said hey get in the car now
they think now they later did catch you
did this and it was somebody that knew
her although they're not sure if he
killed other people so she gets in the
car with him and they the car
significantly that that she was seen
getting into was a gray I believe it's a
ford meteor or is it yeah I think it's a
Ford and now this was the same type of
car that Stephen Truscott said that he
saw Alan Harper getting into when he
turned around on his bike and saw her
getting into car he said it was a gray
car looked like a Ford or maybe a Chevy
but he thought it was probably afford so
like I said this could be the same dude
so they found Georgia quite a while
after she disappeared she had been raped
and bludgeoned in the head two times
with what appeared to be a bottle one of
the creepiest things was that the killer
had taken one of her ears there was also
a strip of skin missing from her arm
which appeared to have been pulled off
with teeth damn so this is a specific
type of you know paraphilic like I said
like I was saying before there's a very
specific type of thing with a guy you
know taking souvenirs and [ __ ] like that
right now
this happened in 1966 they actually
found out who did it in 1971 and it was
interesting because the cops this guy
wasn't even on the cops radar they
actually caught him because he confessed
it too because he was a jehovah's
witness as well and he actually
confessed it to the elders and the
elders went to the cops and knocked on
him so good for them I mean you know
what I mean what was he thinking that's
it yeah it's like he wanted to get it
off his chest yes and they were just
like yes tell us everything I've turned
over and then yeah
well I'm glad they did job because it's
like I said he wasn't even look at him
over did the [ __ ] moon yeah to
justice
yeah his name was David bodemer now the
creepy thing he was married and he had
three kids and he knew Georgia quite
well he was in that bar all the time
like he his job he worked for the the
railway and his job was to go around and
look for damage like on the railway
so he could report like so the cruise
could come and fix it so he was a you
know one of your mobile killers yeah um
you know going from place to place so
you know and like I said Georgia
you know Georgia Jackson the victim she
had known his wife since she was a kid
so she knew him very well and that's why
she didn't think it was strange like
when he was you know coming you know he
was sitting by the place where she
worked and was like hey I can give you a
ride it's nice and warm and stuff and
she was like they said she hesitated at
first because she was like oh he's a
married man and she was very religious
and she's like how would this look like
me getting in the car but then she
finally got in there she didn't think
anything of it she's known him for a
really long time and he ended up killing
her now they don't actually know he like
I said he was given life in prison but
he only served 10 years and then he kind
of went and disappeared there were some
other murders and some other areas that
had a similar type of signature that
they speculate might have been him
especially since most of the jobs he had
you know entailed a lot of travel so but
they definitely know that he did that
one and he might have done other ones as
well now when I talk about this one too
because this one's creepy is [ __ ] okay
and this one is also unsolved this was
the murder of Jacqueline Dunleavy this
happened in January of 1968 again it's a
girl coming home from work she was only
16 years old so she was still in high
school three days a week she worked
part-time at this place called the
Stanley variety store which was owned by
a guy named Joe Clark now this was kind
of like like a variety store they sold
like housewares and candy and [ __ ] like
that but it was also kind of a hangout
for some pretty shady characters some
criminal activity going on and they're
like kids would come and fence stuff
that was stolen Joe Clark had some like
bootleg stag movies and like porn stuff
and he would like let his special
customers come in the back and watch the
porn and you know various other things
so there was like a lot of seedy
[ __ ] hanging around there and
Joe Clark had a habit of hiring cute
teenage girls to work there to kind of
draw in even more characters I guess
and this ended up biting them in the ass
big time because this poor 16 year old
girl that worked there she gets out of
work at you know 6:30 something like
that and she goes to wait for her bus
someone sees her getting in what appears
to be a white sedan and she disappears
now they actually found her later on
that night the killer did not make any
attempt to hide her body it was a very
very cold out it was January they had
left her in the parking lot which was a
fairly busy parking lot left her out in
the open
mostly naked she was laying posed with
her arms by her side and her legs
together as though she was on a mortuary
slab she had obviously you know her her
clothes were kind of scattered around it
looked like the person had driven her
there in the car had taken her body like
about 30 feet I think here 30 yards
posed it there and then gone back to the
car to get her clothes in her purse and
stuff and like put it by the body like
it was some kind of ritualistic type of
thing and we do this in middle of night
no it wasn't it was she was taken at
about 6:30 p.m. and they found her at a
little past 8:00 p.m. okay like some
boys that were going through the time so
this was someone that was not afraid of
getting caught this was a risk-taking
individual they found traces of blood I
don't think she was actually raped but
they did find semen on her clothing they
found vomit on her clothing and also
blood she had actually been strangled
and her face and head were also kind of
beat up as though someone in a car had
been like punching her
they actually got really good
photographs of the tire tracks of the
car that had left her there and they
said not only did this car have four
tires that were completely that were
firm completely different makes and
models there were different sizes but
they said this cars alignment is the
worst alignment we have ever seen and we
can't believe that this car is actually
driving on the road in the winter time
with these mismatched tires and a lie
this bad so the fact that facts you know
made them think oh well we'll catch this
guy like immediately all we have to do
is drive around until we find some
junker with these [ __ ] oh did they let
that out in the public domain um I don't
know if they did that might have come
out later on right now a very specific
thing that they didn't find until they
actually went and you know we're doing
the autopsy on Jacqueline Dunleavy was
that her killer had taken a pack of pink
facial tissues like Kleenex that were
wrapped in cellophane and stuffed it
down her throat evidently postmortem so
this was like a signature type thing and
there would actually be another one
where this happened although I'm not
sure if they're linked or not but yeah
so that was a another kind of paraphilic
type of thing where that was this tissue
thing we're just cramming it down her
throat so yeah yeah it was he raping her
orally and she vomited yeah that was a
possibility
later Ronnie stuff and things diner
throws after she's dead yeah now the
interesting thing about this I mean
because she worked at the Stanley
variety and there were a bunch of like
[ __ ] weirdos and pedophiles and
exhibitionists and rapists and porn
connoisseurs that were in and out of
there all the time they really had no
shortage of suspects but they never had
enough to pin it on any one of them for
a while they even thought maybe the guy
that owned the store Joe Clark that
maybe he had something to do with it
because he actually sold the store and
took off like not long after the murder
but they're not sure if that's because
he knew who murdered her or if he had
done it or if it was because he was
afraid he was going to get in trouble
because you know the killer went there
or you know or all of his illegal
activities within the store would be
exposed or what-have-you so like I said
they don't really know but they're
assuming that it was somebody that
frequented that place because like I
said a lot of people that went there had
committed other crimes in other areas
you know sexual assaults pedophilia one
guy when he was a juvenile had killed a
seven-year-old girl by hanging her
and then jacked off while he watched her
die but he since he'd done it as a
juvenile he'd you know spent some time
in the juvenile system and then we was
later let out so this was the type of
people that was hanging out in this
place so like I said they had no
shortage yeah
seems like it was more of that cuz more
prevalent an or something you don't
really hear that I know it's like I
wonder if it was because now like I said
when I'm reading this book and they're
you know and I've read other things or
you know from this time period
particularly you know in Canada in the
UK in the United States it seems like
there was a lot of this [ __ ] up kind
of [ __ ] is it just because now it's not
like you can have like these kind of
like fetishes and stuff like that and it
does not really considered like deviant
behavior I mean obviously pedophilia is
bestiality is do it but you know just
having normal like sadomasochistic now
yeah it's like it's not really
considered all that weird and so maybe
there's not I don't the repression
really isn't there that's what I mean so
maybe dying breed I mean you don't care
about this happening all the time yeah
last time a serial killer has been
discovered you know a couple years yeah
and they don't really seem to be as
dramatic or as prevalent as they used to
be yeah I think it's a dying breed
really it seems like it's giving way to
mass murderers like mass shooter type
situations it's a different face and
it's a different yeah and mass murderers
and serial killers are completely
different from a psychological profiling
standpoint are two completely different
it's not sexually motivated right and
yeah and most serial killings are not
always but the large majority of them
are even even if there's no rape
happening it's still some kind of like
power control yeah domination type of
issue that sometimes is like sexually
motivated an interesting thing and this
is a little bit it's not off-topic but
this is something that I read in
Psychology Today because I was curious I
was like what is the percentage between
of male to female serial killers what's
the ratio I wanted to know what the
exact ratio was turns out the ratio is
85% male serial killers 15%
female serial killers interestingly
among one-time killers its 90% male 10%
female yeah
another interesting thing about female
serial killers is that they tend to do
it for much longer children
the average well it's not always it's
usually people they work with or people
they know or people in their family like
relatives things like that they tend to
because they tend to like not rape
corpses and torture people and stuff
like that they tend to get away with it
a lot longer they use less flashy
methods poisoning smothering things like
that they said the average for female
serial killer victims is nine that's the
number of victims they usually operate
for eight to eleven years always work
alone and the average for male serial
killers is only two years before they
get caught or killed so I thought that
was kind of interesting and they said
that women almost always kill for
pragmatic reasons rather than you know
they usually for power or for money or
for other things not first two different
kinds of [ __ ] up it is too [ __ ] up
so I just thought that was kind of an
interesting little thing I read it in
Psychology Today
I thought I'd mentioned - because you
were talking about a book that you read
about like the definition of serial
killer and stuff like that and I noted
that the definition of serial killers
was actually changed in 2006 okay it now
now to be a serial killer you have to
have only killed two people okay but
there has to be a signature present
usually like some type of compulsion
some type of sexual signature so I'm
just a fetishistic type of signature
idealistic that is evident after the
second crime like that they can
immediately link those two then there's
like an actual like a specific no I'm
just saying that's what the new
definition is I think about that that
means that Old West gun fighters could
probably be defined as serious well no
not really because it's not no because
they they don't have like a paraphilic
signature they're not doing it for the
signature I would think could you say
that the signature was gun fighting
itself
drooly the same it's not the same okay
cuz like I said it's not like a sexual
cuz he's usually a sexual motive yeah
you know what I mean or something like
that
those guys like to fight though yeah but
it's not the same thing that's not the
same okay you know I mean I mean sure
you could argue it but I don't I don't
think that's like the same thing they
weren't really doing it for the same
reasons I don't feel like yeah that's
just regular guy [ __ ] some of they had
to do with cocaine a lot of people don't
realize that that can you guys it's
probable it was a blast
yeah it was legal you could get it you
could get it from the dentist and Doc
Holliday you know was a coke freak no
basically you know he would sit there
and just pour cocaine into into his
drinks all night long I don't know if
they snorted it back then I don't think
they did yeah I thought it was drink it
yeah they'd drink it drink it in wine
yeah the same effect yeah not as
efficient you have to drink more of it
but it was cheap then you know I think
you get it definitely he could walk
around a big old jar of it but fastest
gun in the West may have had more than
one meaning that's pretty that's I think
that's a new shirt he's got that weird
twitch you better watch it watch it
watch it
hell of a dragon
all right so he's a hell of a drug yeah
all right so let's see all right so the
next one we're gonna talk about is
Frankie Jensen now this is actually one
of the little boys that was murdered
during this time period this happened in
February of 1968 now this little kid he
was nine years old
he packs his little lunchbox and he goes
to walk to school like he does every
morning now usually his older sister
would go with him but she was running
late that day so she you know he was
like okay well I'll just go myself it
was freezing cold and everything so he
goes it's only like a half mile walk to
his little school or whatever and he
never makes it there now the interesting
thing about this was that initially
even though there had been a few murders
before this they weren't thinking murder
they just thought oh he got lost or he
got waylaid and then you know but since
they didn't find him overnight they said
well obviously he's gonna be dead
because it was freezing cold outside and
he would have died of exposure and
everything now another thing too that I
thought was interesting and I said it's
it's such a more naive time back then I
guess despite all of this horrible [ __ ]
going on was that even though little
kids who would take this shortcut
through this little wooded area like to
get to the school and they had been
reporting for years that there were like
old men and [ __ ] like that that were
like messing with little kids but I
would like grab them and be like hey
dude stuff like that so it was like a
known thing but back then police are
just like as crazy it's like nobody
don't sleep underneath bridges trolls
yes I really thought that much about it
it's just kind of like when this other
one like you know one of the suspects in
one of the later cases like they go
through his house and find like pigs
like child porn and stuff like that and
it's like I don't know like technically
I guess it was illegal but it wasn't
really considered that big a deal like
to have child porn in your house they
were just calling this is a weird zany
[ __ ] you know that's weird [ __ ]
yeah it's like they didn't really I mean
nowadays they'd lock you up forever but
it's probably rightfully so but it's
like back then it was just kind of
considered and even then like old dudes
like attacking little boys and little
girls in the woods and it's like they
didn't really think dude do anything
about that evidently there was some
weird [ __ ] like that going on in the
Victorian era the 1800s a.m. I doubt it
a lot of those little cherub drawings
and Arab photos of little naked kids
everything there were some guys that
would collect lots of that yeah
everything Lewis Carroll the guy who did
who wrote Alice in Wonderland evidently
was he had a little bit of that yeah
yeah where he's right down in his
Diaries of death
he's meeting these little girls these
little homeless well Alice Liddell who
he sorry for was only ten years old at
the time and he wrote some pretty I
wrote I read a book about it a few years
he wrote some pretty weird [ __ ] even for
Victorian times
yeah they had pedophilia back then yeah
it's just I don't think they considered
it they know what it was so they just
kind of rolled with it yeah it's like
they didn't consider it bad or so I
don't know it's just seems really and
you know they weren't in do you know it
was like like what would you call it
pornography would have been really taboo
back then but it was nothing to like
have naked pictures of children yeah
their house weird just weird we're
thinking like oh it's just innocent yeah
you know yeah sure put some wings on him
the Romans yes that makes it not for
this yeah if you put wings on it because
it's fiction one of the Roman paintings
you know there's people having sex and
then there's animals in the background
and cherubs coming down and helping
people have sex and children's watch it
let me help you with it ha man come on
man you know what was going on yeah the
Emperor's had Islands you know of little
children dressed up like little nymphs
and pans and satyrs and [ __ ] in their
gardens and you know what you know you
know what's going on yeah of course but
like I said it's just funny that they
didn't really think anything of it
well a historian said that it was
immoral that like Tiberius emperor
Tiberius they didn't like that yeah yeah
and when he got tired of me throw him
off a cliff if they need to gave him a
problem yeah Caligula was one of them
that was his nephew there and that's why
he turned out to be a monster yeah they
had some freakazoids back in the net
period too it's just well there's
there's been freakazoid sent over to you
in history it's just that I think you
hear about it more now like it's more
okay to talk about we have a mechanism
of freakazoid control it is when you're
poor enough to be controlled yeah
starting to come out that rich people do
whatever the [ __ ] they want they run the
system like I said they always have yeah
they got guys in Saudi Arabia that have
whole harems of children and women and
our politicians go over there go hang
out with those guys
so what the hell is going on over there
yeah well whatever they want I guess
like I said you have enough money you
can shield yourself yeah yeah but so
okay so like I said they find no trace
of Frankie Jensen he has disappeared
then a little bit later like I said
they're still kind of like oh maybe he
just wandered off or got lost or
whatever and then a witness comes
forward and says you know the day before
that kid disappeared
I saw a car right by that path and it
was a white sedan just like the one that
had been seen picking up Jacqueline
Dunleavy so I don't know if these two
are related or not the victim profile is
different but that doesn't necessarily
mean anything they actually ended up
finding Frankie Jensen on April 12th
1968 and that was like two months after
he went missing
they found him in a river they said
actually he'd been dumped off a bridge
if he hadn't got caught like on a little
obstacle or something his body would
have just been carried out into the
larger River or whatever and they
probably would have never found him one
interesting thing and they didn't think
anything of this now Dennis Alsop's a
detective I was talking about the
beginning he actually did kind of think
of this because it was another murder
that happened like this one and this is
like a weird little detail so they said
they found Frankie Jensen's body was in
the water they found most of his stuff
except for his boots they found like his
little thermos it is a lunch box and
everything he was wearing his little
undershirt and his regular shirt but his
pants had come off and they determined
that the pants had come off when he was
stored in the water like they weren't
taken off by the killer and then thrown
off you know what I mean they come off
like after you went in the water now
there was another victim later that had
the same thing happened Scott Leishman
and Dennis Alsop noticed he's like the
way that the pants were configured like
the way the belt was the way the zipper
was they said that's something that the
killer did on purpose he loosened the
pants so that when he threw the boys
into the water the pants would come off
and then the killer could think about it
later on that's what I mean by a
paraphilia he had a very specific
fantasy and Dennis Alsop was one of the
first people to like relate those two
things are like think that's what I mean
so like they have these literally waters
yeah yeah then pants are coming off in
the water kind of freaky dude that's
what I mean it's like these are very
very weird specific little details and
little fantasies that they have that
they have to you know that they have to
kind of fulfill I know what you think
Tom when you think about it it's it's
it's like it's like childish in a way
very childish well yeah and like I said
it's a throwback it's usually something
to happen in a childhood like some kind
of traumatic thing that happened in them
a childhood that made them relate
certain primitive and childish
yeah immature yeah Canada and now
another thing about Frankie Johnson's
murder that could have really didn't
with Jacqueline done leave it but
they're not really sure is that Frankie
Jensen also had pink facial tissues
stuffed down his throat but they weren't
in a package this time they were just
like wadded up and stuff down in there
now they did think though that because
the victim profiles were different
because the way the bodies were left was
different I mean Jacqueline's done lady
she was left in the open obviously they
wanted her found she was left at a very
posed position a sexually humiliating
position whereas Frankie Jensen it
looked like the person had like tried to
conceal the body by throwing it in water
and hoping it would get washed out so
they're thinking that whoever killed
Frankie Jensen had read about the
Jacqueline Dunleavy and the and the
tissue thing and thought he would do
that like as a copycat signatures they
don't actually think that those two were
related but they think one was a copycat
of the other you know what I'm saying
yeah um that they were trying to like
throw off the police is basically what
they were trying so then there was
another one in March of 1968 another
little boy named Scott Leishman like I
said same type of thing he was actually
a little bit older than Frankie Jensen
he was 16 but looked much younger he was
on spring break from school and it was a
nice warm day so he was gonna go out
fishing and he went to hitchhike out to
a spot where he was gonna fish and he
disappeared he was found in May of 1968
and same type of thing they found him in
the water and his pants had come on
similar type of things so they think
that he didn't have any tissues in his
throat but because of the pants thing
and because of the way that the and and
they actually couldn't determine like
the they died from head trauma so they
don't know if they knocked him
unconscious and they threw them in water
they dry
or if they hit them with something else
and then they were dead and then they
threw them in the water or whatever they
couldn't really determine because the
water was really cold so they couldn't
tell how long they'd been in there so
those two were probably related then
there was another one in August of 1968
now this woman was a little bit older
she her name is Helga beer she had just
been she was originally from Germany but
had lived in London Ontario for about
seven years
she was actually she had just newly
divorced and she was kind of going out
with her friends and stuff like that
this one particular night she goes to
her old apartment building where some of
her friends still lived now she gets
there sometime around 1:00 a.m. like the
friend who was a female who she
originally went to see was seen to leave
the apartment building with a suitcase
and then she got the [ __ ] out of Dodge I
don't know where she went they never
could find her afterward
now Helga beer was seen leaving the
apartment with this guy who nobody knew
who it was but a lot of people said that
he had this really really round face and
a really wide nose a couple of witnesses
commented on that but they never found
him either now the next day they found
Helga beers BW beetle like backed into a
space at like a service station and her
body was inside it and she had been
beaten that appeared with the fist or
perhaps an iron bar and she was like
stuffed into the space between the front
and back seats she had had sex but they
weren't sure if it was consensual or not
they thought maybe it was the same
killer as Jacqueline Dunleavy because
she'd been left in a sexually
humiliating position like she still had
the top half of her clothes on but not
the bottom half they had taken the
bottom half and kind of threw them
around everywhere so you know there was
that and the sad thing about this one is
because she was in her 30s and you know
not a little kid and she was kind of you
know a swingin divorcee type of thing as
they said back then they would be a
normal woman a normal woman yet like I
said they didn't really consider it all
back then which is really sad so she
didn't get the crime wasn't really as
well investigated as girls but that's
what I mean that as some of the other
ones were because three [ __ ] those
[ __ ] right that's what I mean that
it's almost kind of like a thing where
Oh
well you divorced your husband you know
that happens that's what happens you're
asking for it pretty much I mean you
know what I mean
whereas you know if it's a little kid or
a little teenagers going to school or go
to work or whatever it's like oh it's an
innocent victim so we can that's okay to
feel bad about that but just because you
know what I mean it was another era yeah
it's [ __ ] up I mean like I said
there's still a little bit of that now
but it's like a lot so how much do we
really know I mean we really weren't
there I mean turns out that a lot of the
things that we thought weren't going on
really we're going on like you know
young adults in the 1950s a lot of them
lived with their parents and a lot of
you know most women actually worked even
though they were raised as housewives
there's a lot of [ __ ] that what they
tell us yeah like I said my grandmother
you should tell me that all the time
she's like you know they have this thing
like all the TV shows from the 50s like
a woman stays home and does all the
housework but it's like most of I mean
um well I mean I come from a very
working-class background it's like
pretty much every woman I knew like
older or younger always worked outside
of the home in Mississippi my
grandmother she worked yeah my girls
regretted her whole life yeah I mean she
was married yeah yeah I mean later she
stayed home because my grandfather had
you know he worked at NASA I think my
grandmother Mississippi only stayed home
for a little while when the kids were
really young yeah then once I got to a
certain age they had nannies and they
went back to work yeah yeah like I said
so I think that's kind of yeah maybe
that happened in the 70s like it you
know a lot more women went out into the
workforce but I mean women were always
in the workforce yeah you know before
that like it's but like I said
working-class women you couldn't afford
not to be just like nowadays even in the
south black women were in the working
yeah of course forced you know and a lot
of them worked in white households like
I've told you my grandmother when she
this is way back in the day you know
when she went back to work even though
she was married
it was always black nanny's and you know
the house help is what they called him
back then yeah there weren't enough jobs
in the normal you know economy of
Mississippi for everybody to work people
just worked for other families yeah I
get cooks and yard people just like you
have not we have guys that come and cut
yards you know I mean in Mississippi it
was just back in those days it was just
the black people yeah yeah just what
that was the reality of it
just wasn't enough jobs there weren't
enough jobs for white people yeah back
then just another era
wait wait wait [ __ ] worked just funny
how the movies of the time portray it in
a way that it really wasn't I think that
kind of happens a lot we always tend to
see the past in a rosier life I feel
like yeah it's that bowl in the stall
jairos colored glasses type of thing
yeah you know what I mean so yeah that's
why I feel like a lot of people that you
know that are old now that you grew up
then I think they forget like how shitty
it really was back then and they just
like remember the good [ __ ] yeah I mean
so I'm just saying it's like you know I
I try not to be like that about you know
I grew up in the 70s and 80s it's like
yeah some [ __ ] was cool and everything
like that but I don't forget like how
crappy a lot it was either it's like I
wouldn't go back yeah and just and also
you know we're both product kind of
products of southern families the way
the South is portrayed is not the really
the way it was yeah
like I thought that in the pre
segregation days that there was very
little contact between white and black
people and evidently I was reading some
stuff earlier best Lee around where my
family comes from Jones County which is
called the Free State of Jones in pre
segregation pre okay pre segregation was
pre segregation you had black people
white people living together they were
actually getting married and this is in
the slave days they were getting married
but they had free black people it wasn't
until segregation after slavery that
there was actual physical segregation
where that where those farmers didn't
live right up next to each other yeah
it's just fine we're off topic yeah
you're right you're running with
Kukulcan yeah just thinking about the
past how different it actually was it's
not the way it was yeah we were right
yeah how the past is always portrayed in
like way what really was this golden
light which yeah and like I said I think
people talk about even and even in the
case of like serial killers and stuff
like that oh [ __ ] like that never used
to happen yeah it did I mean like I said
I've been researching this [ __ ] for like
you did you know even if it's far back
as 1902 is all
horrible [ __ ] happening but it's like
you know you look back though is a more
innocent time yeah no it wasn't in fact
I think people back then were worse
right alright so the next one I want to
talk about this was the case of Linda
White and this happened in November in
1968 now she was a student at Huron
College Western University and she lived
in a house with a couple of roommates
that she'd also gone to school with now
on November 13th she just finished a
midterm in French and she asked some of
her friends hey you want to go down to
the tavern that all the students went to
and it's like yeah we'll go blow off
some steam because we finished our tests
and all this other kind of stuff and a
bunch of mister like now we'll go later
or whatever so she just she got a ride
from two of her buddies had their male
friends of hers that usually drove her
around in the wintertime so she didn't
have to walk so far cuz she lived quite
a long distance from campus now they
dropped her off a couple blocks from her
apartment and she henceforth disappeared
now the weird thing was that when she
didn't come home and then she you know
her bed hadn't been slept in and stuff
so her roommate started freaking out and
they started calling her family now her
brother John like drove over a hundred
miles from the home to come and help
look for her they look all over the
campus they looked at the apartment he
checked the train station he checked
everywhere now the weird thing was that
the first time they looked through the
apartment they looked through a room and
everything and they didn't find anything
out of the ordinary when they searched
the apartment again
they found Linda's clothes that she'd
been wearing like when she took the exam
and they were like all wadded up and
like stuffed underneath the comforter on
her bed now they're not sure if they
just missed that the first time around
or if somebody came in subsequently
while they were gone and they were out
searching other places and put them
there is like some kind of weird
signature or something like that but
that was like a really weird detail
there was nothing there was no blood on
the clothes they weren't you know or
anything like that it doesn't look like
anything bad had happened or they didn't
know if she had come back and change
clothes if for some reason stuck the
clothes under there and then took off
again they didn't really know now they
actually did not find her for almost
five years it was four and a half years
later they didn't find her till May of
1973 and at that point they found there
was a farmer and he was kind of looking
around his little area or whatever
he finds this clothing that was like
wrapped around a surveyors pole and then
they thought oh okay that looks like the
clothing that Linda White was supposedly
wearing or that the clothes that
belonged to her then about a month later
they find a skeleton now this skeleton
had clearly been posed by the killer
they said it was laid out they compared
it to vitruvian man yeah were the arms
and legs you know the oh yeah Leonardo
DaVinci came with the arms and legs
sticking out one of the arms was gone
but they said that that probably wasn't
animal activity like there was some way
that they could tell that was an animal
activity so they thought this might be
kind of a you know David bodemer killer
type of situation where he like took the
arm because remember he chewed chewed
off the arm of that one girl so they
thought maybe there was some connection
there but yes so they couldn't they
couldn't actually determine how she had
died because she'd been out there so
long but the interesting thing was they
said as long as she'd been out there she
hadn't been out there as long as she'd
been missing which meant that the killer
had kept her somewhere for some
significant period of time either they
kept her somewhere alive or they kept
her body frozen before they dumped it
like where it was found so there was
another one like that that happened to
you later on that they think was the
same killer now this one was Patricia
boven this happened in April of 1969 she
was 22 she had also recently divorced
her husband she had two little kids at
home April 22nd somebody just came into
her house and basically stabbed her to
death and she was just laying on the
floor in the blood stabbed her about a
dozen times and left the two little kids
you know unharmed they said when they
first came in the apartment and she's
dead in a puddle of blood the kids were
crying and you know hungry and
everything like that and they said there
was like there was like chairs and [ __ ]
tipped over and they thought that there
had been some kind of robbery or some
type of thing but they determined that
the little kid
and this is horrible this is like this
detail always creeps me out the little
kids have been trying to get up in the
cabinets to get food right and they were
just little so it's like they were
pushing the chairs over to the cabinets
like to get the food their mom was dead
they were in there for like all that
time I was like it was actually I think
there's only a day or two until she got
found but still that's like that's awful
I mean there was a sliver little what if
they remember now Patricia boven they
think might have been murdered by the
same guy that killed this other girl
named Victoria Mayo and this happened in
1964 now this was almost the exact same
thing it was kind of like a break-in
or actually there was no forced entry so
it might have been you know either
someone that they knew or some they were
able to talk their way in
same type of thing Victoria Mayo she
lived in a house with her kid somebody
came in stabbed her to death let the kid
unharmed now they actually did find out
who did that one is this guy named
Sandor Fulop he was Hungarian so they
actually did match in 2000 they matched
his DNA to DNA found at the Victoria
Mayo scene so they said speculate that
he probably killed Patricia boban as
well though he's dead now so I guess
they're never gonna know you're talking
so much if the baby could be asleep
she's laying on her back sorry today did
I bore you baby okay you guys got to see
this she's on her back all right
now we're getting okay we're getting
like two into this so I'm just gonna
skip some of the kids yeah these cases
about to get all right but let me talk I
just want to mention this one and then
I'll just mention a couple other ones
really quick because this case was kind
of a big deal now this case was the case
of Jackie English and there's actually
if you want to go look there was a to
catch a killer with michael arndt field
they did a whole episode about this this
happened in 1969 same kind of deal she
was 15 years old she worked as a
waitress in a diner that was in a
department store she leaves work one
night goes out to the over
pass to catch a bus somebody sees her
getting into the backseat of a car so
they don't know if it was somebody she
knew or not and then she disappeared
October 9th
they found her naked body floating face
up in big Otter Creek the weird thing
was everything of hers was gone except
the killer had taken off her - clasp
earrings and like placed them next to
her like almost as like a weird thing
and there was a ring left on her finger
but that was about it she'd been killed
by a single blow to the back of the head
now she had not obviously been sexually
assaulted they did find semen inside her
body but it was the same blood type as
her boyfriend and since she had spent
the day before her murder with her
boyfriend they assumed that that was
probably consensual they found some of
her clothing later on and there was a
different semen profile on the underwear
so they don't know if the serial killer
there was rape or if the serial killer
like jacked off into her underwear like
after she was dead or something like
that they were finding clothes of hers
all over the place like in the weeks and
months like following the you know her
body being found now later on this woman
named Elizabeth Harrison came forward
and she said you know me and my husband
and kid were at the diner where Jackie
worked the night she disappeared and we
saw these two guys talking to her like
at different times they were both she
said they were both dark-haired they
looked very similar she's like in fact
they looked so similar that it could
have been the same dude like in two
different outfits like at two different
times she said that they were both
talking to Jackie and that after the
second conversation she looked very
frightened now after Elizabeth Harrison
came forward and the police produced a
composite sketch based on her
description Elizabeth Harrison started
getting obscene phone calls she started
getting like someone would like knock on
her door and then run off and like drive
off in a car she got a sympathy card in
her mail like somebody stuck into her
mailbox and inside somebody had written
watching you and then really much
scarier later on she was out she took
her dog to a dog park you know one late
afternoon was letting the dog run around
she gets back in her car and this dude
gets in the car
there holds a knife to her throat and
then he says something about turned the
dome light on I like to watch I like to
have sex with dead girls because they'll
do whatever I want
then he started slashing at her face he
slashed her face all up he stabbed her
in the thigh
you know he [ __ ] her all up she
actually um she ran him off her and the
dog he took off and then she drove to
the emergency room and they fixed her up
but they they actually got a guy later
on that they thought might have been him
his name is Gary or fryer or fly or
something something like that and he was
actually a school principal and she said
she wasn't sure if this was the same guy
that she had seen in the store the night
that Jacquie English was murdered but
she said his voice for sure sounded like
the guy that kept calling her and
threatening her over the phone but he
went to trial and he was acquitted now
for a long time they thought maybe he
was responsible for not only Jacquie
English's murder but a couple of other
ones like from Sirois O'Connell and a
white because they think those three
were related because they go through his
house and found like all these weird
photographs like child porn
they found mason jars full of poop but
evidently hyouka file yes so he had like
a trunk with like all these poop filled
mason jars whose it was doing
who-knows-what with sticking his dick in
there but it's like yeah so this guy he
actually went on trial for attacking
Elizabeth Harrison but was acquitted for
a long time they suspected that maybe he
had something to do with it but I think
later on DNA evidence exonerated him of
most of the stuff that he was suspected
of but you know he seems kind of like
scum George will the poop you guys but
yes so and another yes well I guess
another creepy thing too is that not
that long after Jack the English was
killed the killer took some of her stuff
likes over cosmetics and like a little
bag that had her name in it and stuff
and made like a little shrine in front
of what was once her family home now her
family did not live there anymore they
had moved away not long after her murder
but I guess the murderer didn't know
that so he left it like on a sidewalk in
front of there and then later on that
house burned down
and killed the family that lived in
there in wasn't Jackie English's family
and then Elizabeth Harrison the woman
who had been cut up who said that she
saw the people you know the night that
Jackie English disappeared her house
burned down and her whole family died
too
he must have been doing both of those
and both of the fires were ruled
accidental I'm like yeah I don't think
so statistically unlikely that's what I
was saying I mean for those two [ __ ]
houses there was also a whole thing with
this case there was a thing about a girl
named Marilyn Hurd who they found she
actually worked at the store with Jack
English was about the same age and she
tried to kill herself they found her
like in a street she had overdosed or
whatever and she they found a picture of
Jackie English in her pocket and on the
back of it it said let her killer let
the name of her killer die with me or
something like that but she never would
tell the police they didn't know she was
just a crazy person and she really did
know I mean she did know Jackie English
but they don't know she really knew like
who killed her or not so there was that
whole thing and then let me see okay so
there were a couple other ones
Irene Gibbons who was like an older
woman and she was actually killed in her
house same type of thing I think one of
the last one in the series is usually
Donna Alcock which happened in October
of 1983 and she was actually she had
gone to babysit at the building next to
hers and I guess when the mom of the
kids came back from the bar she was
super drunk she had come back with a
some Rando she had picked up at the bar
she said hey wait in the car I'm gonna
go up and you know pay the babysitter or
whatever and then Donna the babysitter
you know the mom gave her money and said
hey why don't you go buy me some
cigarettes I'm too drunk to walk over
there so Donna goes to the store to buy
her cigarettes and then she disappears
and she turns up dead later on so
they're still they say they were looking
for the stranger in the car that this
person had picked up in the bar she was
too drunk to remember what he looked
like now other than all of these
unsolved murders and like I said I
couldn't get into all of them I had like
a bunch more of my notes but I didn't
know it would take to go through all of
it a lot of them were in my book so if
you're really interested you can read it
or you can read murder City by Michael
art field I also wanted to mention
really quick that three the three serial
killers that were eventually caught in
London Ontario were Gerald Thomas Archer
the London chambermaids layer so-called
because his three victims were all
elderly women who worked as maids in
hotels and they were all stabbed there
was also a guy named Russell Johnson
known as the bedroom strangler or the
balcony killer for a while he got away
with murder for a long time because his
MO at first was to climb up the outside
of the house like [ __ ] spider-man he
would go into people's houses but you
know overthrew the balcony and then he
would smother them with a pillow in a
way that made it look like they had
smothered themselves accidentally how do
you do that that's what I don't know but
it's like so the first four crimes he
did they weren't even they weren't even
ruled homicides at first because the the
women that he picked were on particular
medications where it could have happened
like they took too many and then like
they rolled over and smothered
themselves in their sleep which is what
it looked like
so they actually didn't catch him for
quite a while he ended up getting
convicted of one two three four five six
seven murders I believe and then there
was another guy christian mcgee called
the mad slasher and he actually ended up
killing three women by slashing their
throats he would just come up to them
and the street and slash their throats
so what was that with this particular
area I mean why why did this all happen
here this is whatever this is what is
actually really fascinating to me and
what he says in the book is it's
probably a combination of factors like I
said you know serial killers were kind
of becoming a big deal all over the
place at least in the Western world
during this time one of the things that
he mentions is the highway system now
obviously the u.s. serial killing you
know statistics went up you know as our
highway system got bigger what most
people don't know is that the Canadian
highway system predates ours by four or
five years so you know when this big
highway system started to open up London
Ontario was suddenly I mean it was a
small city it wasn't like a little town
but it wasn't like a big
it's like in the middle you know what I
mean like a mid-sized city but previous
to that it had been kind of isolated a
little bit from all the rural
communities around it and whatnot and
now suddenly it was opened up so he
thinks that's probably a significant
factor there was also and this was
actually one of the weirdest things that
I thought London Ontario is actually
considered he's like the same things
that make cities attractive to marketers
like in in the sense of test marketing
like we're gonna try this new product in
this town we're gonna chop in this new
franchise in this town and see how it
does before we roll it out nationwide
they're like the same thing that makes
the detractors and marketers also makes
it attractive to a particular type of
violent offender serial killer sexual
serial killers in particular and that's
because for some reason it's average in
every way its average size average
population demographics average income
it has a little bit of everybody it has
some little bit wealthy people a little
bit of students going in and out some
people that have lived there their whole
lives some you know people that are
working class has like a lot of you know
factories and that type of thing where
people work the thing about London
Ontario as well is that it has like an
urban center but the outside of it is a
lot of forest land they call it the
forest city that's what's called just
like Detroit's the Motor City so it
still had like a park like you know
rural atmosphere even though it was a
fairly large city so there was a lot of
places where you could hide there was a
lot of dumping ground type area but but
the thing about it being completely
average in every way demographics wise
he said you see an interesting you see a
similar thing in cities in the United
States particularly Muncie Indiana
Richmond Virginia Rochester New York
he's like where the demographics are
completely average in every way and they
also have a higher than average sexual
serial offender
you know profile for some reason that's
the same thing and
particularly talking about Rochester New
York because [ __ ] we did the show on the
alphabet murders which happened in
Rochester New York and not only that but
there were some serial killers like Ken
Bianchi the hillside strangler Josef
naso who did the other alphabet murders
in California were from Rochester New
York so the thing about London Ontario
is that not only did a bunch of serial
killers serial killings happen within
the city and its surroundings but also
some people that were born there did a
murder there and then went on to become
serial killers elsewhere like they moved
elsewhere their first official serial
killer as a matter of fact was Thomas
Neel cream and remember we did a show
about him a long time ago because they
suspected that he might have been Jack
the Ripper he's the Lambuth poisoner and
he is actually from London London
Ontario and did his first murder there
and then he moved to London England and
then started killing over there okay so
I think whatever saying is the reason
why it happened here is because it's a
big area that's very average and it's
almost kind of suburban yeah you're
talking about you're talking about white
middle-class people yeah just fairly
safe area yeah so so it's not very well
defended it's not a hostile region
people aren't really - it's a bit
isolated it was wrong it was isolated
until the highway system opened it up so
it attracts white predators thinking
yeah freely through there it's not a
well-defended area and they can ply
their trade and get away with it yeah
they couldn't do that in a tougher in
their area they'd get their asses kicked
yeah yeah I mean that's what it is maybe
they do dangerous yeah right so they go
to a safe area where the cute soft girls
are basically what the deal is and like
I said where there's a lot of
surrounding area around here um and yeah
so that's it's a Spielberg Ian area yeah
place where they can ply their trade but
that yeah that was like one of the
weirdest thing and they said but he said
the interesting thing though is that
although it was during this time period
at least the serial killer capital the
world highest concentration of serial
killer
it's not actually the murder capital of
Canada that room that would be Winnipeg
for whatever reason I'm not really sure
but that's like mostly one-off murders
domestic decisions this is serial killer
the offenders were white the offenders
are probably working class or middle
class so they can move freely through
there without being noticed
yeah they're going after their own
racial group yeah
the preferred victim is a teenage girl
there's lots of them there yeah it's a
safe area where they're not really being
defended they're walking around you know
it's a little security area yeah I guess
they're not as wary or not that's what I
mean by not defending right would be in
maybe another area going oh you're going
to a tougher area then everyone's you
know under lock and key and the security
is higher yeah that's more threatening
but they feel safe there so the girls
are just walking around for the taking
yeah really from their point of view but
a parent according to him I'm like once
all that once this book came out and all
this kind of stuff about the the
geography of serial killing kind of came
out so now they're trying to like look
at particular cities and like why their
configuration would may be a more
conducive to their types of offenders
they have serial killers in the hood
yeah they're going after it like the
grim reaper right they're going after a
different rarer it's more rare I think
the people are a little more streetwise
there and the guys that are doing this
are usually go after hookers in the hood
yeah well yeah like Lonnie Franklin was
and we did so and that's why I want to
do a show about him because he's very
unusual for a serial killer you don't
see a lot of I mean yeah there's a lot
of murders in the hood but it's not
usually serial killer type murder no but
what it is it's black on black usually
yeah and but usually like I said it's
always there's other yes sure occurs
almost always hot within their racial
group yeah yeah so I feel like the same
thing I'm like you said it might be just
that the victim profiles like you said
you know your girls in the middle class
and that's yeah they aren't necessarily
you know that are maybe a little bit
naive not blaming you or anything like
that I mean they didn't have any reason
not that's a safe area so they're here
their guards lowered yeah so that's
probably why and like I said that
probably explains a lot of places but I
feel like it was just like a perp
storm and like I said crime everywhere
was going up like in pretty much every
large city during that time just because
of the socio-political evils and various
other things at the time period so it
was just that combined with particular
factors of London Ontario which
specifically just kind of I always had
this thing where the it seems like the
guys that commit these kind of crimes
come from a time and a place where
you're going from a very strict and kind
of restricted kind of culture into a
more permissive culture in other words
they come from a real uptight background
and all of a sudden it's now kind of a
free-for-all yeah and I mean like the
night the 60s happened yeah then the 70s
happened but these guys kind of have a
50s mentality where they're uptight and
they can't make that transition to well
they're they're like in cells and they
start hating women for one cuz they
can't get it other guys are getting it
and they can't get it yeah and then
there's weird fetishistic [ __ ] going on
it would have the same thing would
happened right now in a place like Saudi
Arabia if you it's very uptight if you
were to go in there and say open that
place wide open and give it Western
culture there'd be a lot of serial
murder probably going I guess any big
change a change like the pollution
caused right all kinds of horrible
things right for things stabilized for
things stabilized because any many years
yeah I mean nowadays like I said this
whole serial killer thing in London
Ontario took place from 1959 1984 now
it's one of the safest places in Canada
but for a time there you know though all
that [ __ ] was going on in there it was
just a particular upheaval in that
particular gonna have these guys all of
a sudden these women are wearing
miniskirts and they're walking around
without veils or whatever there's maybe
guys that don't like that they're gonna
go after him
yeah yeah well yeah and I think it says
you know on a smaller scale is probably
a similar type of similar thing has
happened in the United States and Canada
yeah and I think it had to do with the
60s happening sexual revolution of the
60s yeah I think that was a big factor
for you know all the way around but yeah
like I said okay so like I said I this
is like a huge topic and I didn't even
get into like parses part of the stuff I
want to talk about but that's alright so
if you're interested in any of these
cases like I said I wrote about a bunch
of them in my book phases villain part 2
or you can read
merger city by michael arndt field which
is really really good and really
well-written and goes into all like
every single murder that took place all
the solved ones and the unsolved ones
and talks about all the serial killers
like in a kind of a chronological order
plus does a whole bunch of stuff about
serial killer profiling and stuff it's
like a really fascinating book so I
would recommend it so we're we are gonna
wrap up episode 122 and remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe on
all your social media share with all
your friends and family if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
it would be much appreciated and
remember to check out our last movie
review which was the Wicker Man and I
think that'll do it for this particular
episode hope you guys enjoyed it and we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]